>>> ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY
SETTLED?
>> EVERYONE SETTLED IN OKAY?
>> LET'S SETTLE IN, EVERYONE.
>> PLEASE SETTLE.
PLEASE SETTLE.
>> WE'RE SETTLED.
>> ALL RIGHT.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
US, MY NAME IS DONALD.
>> AND MY NAME IS MARIA.
AND WE ARE YOUR HR
REPRESENTATIVES HERE AT LINKS
PHARMACEUTICAL.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE'RE THE ONES YOU COME TO WITH
ANONYMOUS COMPLAINTS, LIKE WHEN
DEBORAH TOLD US WHAT KEVIN WAS
DOING.
>> YOU RATTED ON ME, DEBORAH?
>> I -- I DID NOT.
NO.
WHY WOULD I EVEN CARE THAT YOU
WAIT OUTSIDE THE WOMEN'S ROOM
AND SAY "HOW'D IT GO IN THERE?"
>> JUST A SIMPLE GOOD OR BAD
WOULD SUFFICE.
>> GUYS, WE'RE NOT HERE TO
LECTURE KEVIN AGAIN.
>> GOD KNOWS WE SPENT ENOUGH
TIME ON KEVIN THANKS TO
COMPLAINTS FROM DEBORAH AND
LYLE.
GUYS, TODAY IS OUR ANNUAL
HARASSMENT SEMINAR.
AND I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE THINKING.
WE HAVE TO SIT THROUGH THIS
AGAIN?
AWW, I'M GOING TO BLOW MY
FRIGGING BRAINS OUT!
>> THIS WHOLE SCHPEEL AGAIN?
I'M GOING TO BLOW MY GODDAMN
BRAINS OUT.
>> PLEASE STOP SAYING THAT.
>> WE PROMISE WE ARE GOING TO
GET THIS OVER WITH AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SO YOU CAN GET BACK TO
WORK.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, AND KEVIN CAN
GET BACK TO PEEKING UNDER
BATHROOM STALLS.
>> YOU TOLD THEM ABOUT THAT?
>> YOUR FACE WAS FULLY UNDER MY
STALL.
>> OKAY.
THIS IS REAL SIMPLE, GUYS.
OKAY?
WE'RE JUST GOING TO RUN THROUGH
A COUPLE OF SCENARIOS, AND YOU
GUYS TELL US WHETHER THEY'RE
APPROPRIATE OR INAPPROPRIATE,
OKAY?
>> HERE'S THE FIRST ONE.
>> WHAT IF MARIA SAYS TO DONALD,
"WOW, LOOKS LIKE THOSE WORKOUTS
YOU'VE BEEN DOING ARE REALLY
PAYING OFF"?
>> I WOULD SAY THAT'S
INAPPROPRIATE.
>> WRONG.
>> HM.
LET'S TRY ANOTHER ONE.
OKAY, SO WHAT IF DONALD SAID TO
MARIA, "WOW, HOW OFTEN ARE YOU
GOING TO THE GYM?
YOUR BODY IS SERIOUSLY
FANTASTIC."
>> THAT'S VERY INAPPROPRIATE.
>> SORRY, NO.
>> TRY TO REALLY FOCUS THIS
TIME.
MARIA COMES UP BEHIND DONALD AND
SAYS, "DAMN, DO YOU LIVE AT THE
GYM OR SOMETHING?
BECAUSE THAT JUICY BOOTY SLAPS."
>> WILDLY INAPPROPRIATE.
>> ACTUALLY, IT'S NOT.
BECAUSE I'M HER BOSS.
>> SEE?
TRY TO REALLY LISTEN, GUYS.
>> OKAY, WHAT IF MARIA'S BOSS
SAID TO MARIA, "HEY, WHEN ARE
YOU GOING TO GET TO START
BANGING OUT KIDS?
THAT IS CLOCK IS TICKING, BABY."
>> AGAIN, VERY INAPPROPRIATE.
>> BUT WHAT IF MY BOSS IS MY
GRANDFATHER AND HE JUST REALLY
WANTS GRANDKIDS?
>> OKAY, BUT HE SHOULDN'T SAY IT
AT WORK IN FRONT OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
>> AND WAIT, I THOUGHT DONALD
WAS YOUR BOSS.
>> "I THOUGHT DONALD WAS" -- YOU
KNOW WHAT?
THIS ISN'T A GAME, DEBORAH.
NEXT SLIDE.
>> DONALD SAYS TO MARIA, "HEY,
N-WORD, ARE YOU GOING TO THE GYM
LATER?
OR AM I GOING TO HAVE TO DRAG
YOUR THICK ASS THERE MYSELF?"
>> THAT'S REALLY AWFUL AND
INAPPROPRIATE.
>> ACTUALLY, IT'S FINE.
>> ACTUALLY, IT'S NOT.
>> NO, HE DIDN'T MEAN THAT "N"
WORD.
HE MEANT NICE.
>> HE WAS SAYING, HEY NICE?
>> YEAH.
BECAUSE HE'S ITALIAN.
HE SAID, "HEYA NICE."
ALL THE TIME.
>> THAT'S ALSO INAPPROPRIATE.
>> NOT IF SHE IS MY BOSS.
>> ALSO, WHY ARE ALL OF THESE
EXAMPLES ABOUT THE TWO OF YOU?
>> WOW.
>> THE TWO OF US?
THAT'S HOW YOU SEE IT?
>> WOW, SO YOU SEE A MAN AND A
WOMAN WORKING TOGETHER, SO
AUTOMATICALLY YOU THINK THEY'RE
HAVING RAW INTERCOURSE?
>> NO ONE SAID THAT.
>> YOU SEE A WOMAN IN A HOT
SKIRT SUIT, NOTHING UNDERNEATH,
AND JUST BECAUSE YOUR EYES ARE
GOING OWOOGA THINKING SHE'LL
TAKE A BITE OUT OF HER BOSS'S
SANDWICH, THAT MEANS
AUTOMATICALLY THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE RAW INTERCOURSE.
>> STOP SAYING RAW INTERCOURSE!
>> NO, SHUT UP, DEBORAH, SHUT
UP.
KEVIN WAS RIGHT ABOUT WHAT HE
SAID DURING THE INVESTIGATION,
YOU ARE AN UPTIGHT BITCH.
>> OH MY GOD, THIS IS HORRIBLE.
>> EXACTLY.
>> YOU HEAR THAT?
THAT'S CLAPPING.
>> WE'RE CLAPPING FOR YOU!
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT YOUR HR
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> NO.
WE'RE FROM A GROUP CALLED "IT
COULD BE WORSE."
AND WE SHOW EMPLOYEES THAT NO
MATTER HOW BAD YOUR WORKPLACE
ENVIRONMENT MIGHT BE, IT COULD
BE WORSE.
>> COULD BE WAY WORSE.
OKAY?
>> WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO
WITH THIS INFORMATION?
>> I WANT YOU ALL TO WALK BACK
INTO YOUR OFFICES, TAKE A DEEP
BREATH, JUST START TYPING.
TYPE, TYPE, TYPE, TYPE, TYPE,
TYPE, TYPE --
>> HE HAS NO IDEA WHAT WE DO.
>> TYPE, TYPE, TYPE, TYPE, TYPE
AND RIGHT WHEN YOU'RE FINISHED
TYPING YOUR TYPES AND YOU GO
HOME FOR THE DAY, THE WOMEN TO
THEIR HUNKY HUSBANDS AND THE MEN
TO THEIR SHRILL, NAGGING
WIVES, AND I WANT YOU TO THINK
ABOUT US.
AND HOW WE SHOWED YOU A NEW WAY
TO WORK.
♪♪
A NEW WAY TO LIVE.
MAYBE EVEN A NEW WAY TO LOVE.
>> YOU'LL WONDER, WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO THOSE TWO?
DID THEY END UP GOING TO THE
MEN'S ROOM AND HAVING RAW
INTERCOURSE?
>> AND THE ANSWER IS --
YES.
YES, THEY DID.
>> AND UNRELATED, WHICH STALL
ARE YOU ALL GOING TO BE USING?
>> KEVIN.
>> "KEVIN," FRIDAYS AT 6:00 A.M.
ONLY ON THE WEATHER CHANNEL.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]